- My story consists of
a lot of drug using,
a lot of prostitution,
a lot of street living
and a lot of criminal.
This is what my story consists of.
- [Interviewer] Darnell,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in a city
outside of San Francisco called Pittsburg.
South side of Oakland,
between Frisco and Oakland.
I'm 48 years old at this time.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family.
- My family, I have two
sisters, one brother.
My mom died in 217.
That's all that's left,
it's just me, two sisters
and one brother.
And me.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- It was pretty rough.
It was pretty bad.
I grew up in the projects in Pittsburg.
From I think, we got there in 1972.
In 1972, I think I was
five, six years old,
seven, something like that.
And one of my mother's boyfriends,
he had a tendency of keep
looking at me all the time,
because I was a little guy, first of all,
and he felt that, you
know, that I was a guy that
maybe he wanted to try.
But anyway, to move right along,
I was molested by him three times.
I never told my mother
until two years later.
I finally told her
exactly what he had done
and she didn't accept it,
because she didn't believe me.
Because I waited so long to tell.
So that kind of stuck
with me for a long time,
as I got older, I just
couldn't trust people.
I couldn't trust, especially
mens, that were older than me,
I couldn't trust 'em, I
couldn't be around 'em.
I couldn't stay in a
room too long with 'em,
because I was scared.
I was really afraid.
As time went on,
I alienated myself because of that fact.
I start using drugs at 13.
My first choice of drugs was alcohol.
And from alcohol, I started using cocaine.
I didn't smoke anything,
I just put it in my nose
and I didn't get an effect.
And I always thought about
it like, what does it does?
So it really didn't do anything for me.
So as time went on, by the time I was 15,
I learnt about freebasing.
Back then they called it the freebasing
and this girl showed me how to freebase.
I learnt how to freebase and at that time,
whenever I ran out of money,
I went out and I sold my body
to get the money for the freebase.
That went on for a couple
of years, maybe three years.
And then after that I
did my first prison term,
by the time I was 17 years old.
I did a prison term for breaking
and entering and robbery,
stealing money from an
old guy, he was a trick
and I stole some money
from him and I ran off.
And he called the police on me, anyway.
I did time for that.
I did it until I was 22 years old.
From 17 to 22.
I got out.
You know, my criminology had advanced,
now I know how to do a lot of things.
So, I start boosting, I start
running with crowds that,
shot dope and I got introduce to heron.
And from heron, it just took
me to a whole nother phase.
Because heron is drug,
that you have to have it.
You can not go a day without it.
So I had to go and plan my day, everyday.
I had to have my dope at night
and I had to plan my day,
during the day, to go get money,
for my dope at night.
And I did that for four and a half years.
Straight.
No brakes.
No nothing.
I started, you know,
coming to a point to where
I started getting sick,
where I couldn't eat,
I couldn't sleep, I couldn't do anything,
I didn't even think right.
So I stopped showering,
I stopped taking care of my hygiene.
I stopped doing a lot of things.
I became a full-fledged junkie.
And I started sleeping
on abandoned houses.
And wherever I was able
to get me a fix, I did it.
Whatever it took to get it, I did it.
I did that for years.
By the time I was 25 years old,
I had become someone what they would call,
what the law would call
a full-fledged criminal.
I had started doing all kinds of things.
Forgery, burglary,
robbery,
all kind of things I
was doing to get my fix.
Because I'm a full-fledged heron addict.
And I went through that for six years,
until I was 32 years old,
and I did another prison term
and I cleaned up, because
I did five years in prison.
So I kinda cleaned up
and when I came home,
and I told myself and I
told my family, my siblings
that still here with me today that,
"I will not use any drugs,
no more in my life."
That lasted about seven months.
I met a female at a club
and she had some coke.
And I let her do her
thing, I didn't touch it.
And on the way home she told
me, "You spend the night?
"Wanna do some coke?"
And we kicked back.
And I went into it and I tried some coke.
And I end up wanting more.
Because coke is a trigger for heron.
So once I tried the coke and I told her,
"Well I need something more.
"Can we go get it?"
So I find my way downtown,
I got some heron and she
had never messed with heron.
So I introduced her to the needle.
And from that point on, for eight days,
me and her shot heron.
And ran the streets.
She finally got arrested for shoplifting.
And they put a restraining on me.
I also got arrested too.
They put a restraining order on me,
where I could not have
any dealings with her.
So I went in and I did
14 months on that case.
I got out and I went
straight to the dope dealer.
It's really true.
You know, you're out by eight
and you seein' the dealer by 12.
That's really true.
That happens in real life.
After I've seen the dealer.
I got me some heron.
I laid on the curb, I vomit
everywhere 'cause I was sick,
'cause I hadn't done it in a while.
And you know, your first dose is very bad.
I laid there for two days.
Is what I remember, two days.
People say I was there longer,
but I remember two days.
And I finally woke up and some
guys took me to a mission.
They call it the L.A. Mission.
It's here on Fifth and
Wall Street, I believe.
They took me there, they put me in there.
I was supposed to stay clean for 30 days,
in order for me to treat
the criteria of the mission.
I think I lasted four days.
Four days.
After I ate and slept a couple of days,
I was back on the streets
and I sold my body
and I went and I got me some heron.
And at that time, the guy
that I sold my body to,
he was infected, he had HIV.
But so happen, it didn't infect me.
For some reason, I don't
know, because I wasn't safe.
I just did what I had to
do and just get my heron.
So as time went on, I'm
36 years old at this time.
So as time went on, I start finding myself
not only trickin' but I'm also
letting people take me to mountains,
to resorts, hideaways,
caves,
tunnels.
I'm doing all these things,
just to get my heron.
One day, one time, I stayed
in a cave for nine days.
No heater.
No nothing.
And I didn't eat for six of them days.
When I finally did eat something,
I wasn't able to eat it,
because I hadn't been
accustomed to food at that time.
So I wasn't able to eat it.
I eventually got away from
the guy and I made it back
down in to the city limits.
And once I got to the city limits,
I met a guy and he took me to Las Vegas.
I ended up in Vegas, for
18 days with this guy.
He had me trickin' with other guys
and he paid me $20, each guy.
So I went through that
as long as I was able
to get my heron.
I did that for 18 days and
I finally go away from him.
I ended up in Whiskey Peak,
I found what they call a brothel house,
where womens go and sell their bodies,
and you know they pay the house.
So anyway, I found one and it for mens.
So I end up staying in the brothel house
about I think four and a half months.
I paid my tithes, I did my tricks
and I went out and got my heron.
I did that for four and a half months.
They finally bust me one time,
I had heron in the room
and they kicked me out.
So now I'm down in
Whiskey Peak, in Nevada.
Running around with just
heron in my possession,
and no money.
So I found a guy that had a mobile home.
He let me stay in his
mobile home for eight days,
while I give him drugs.
As long as I was able to give him drugs,
I was able to stay there.
Once I ran out of funds to get drugs
I had to go into the city and
do somethings to get drug.
So I went in and at this time,
they had a sting operation
going on with male prostitution
and I didn't know,
because I was sick and
I just wanted drugs.
So I went in a bar, matter
of fact, the name of the club
is Monte Carlo, it's the casino,
I went in there and I met the guy,
he took me up to his room,
and as soon as I told him
about the price and everything,
they came in and they arrested me.
So I ended up doing 32 months in Nevada,
behind male prostitution.
So I get out of that.
Now, I'm pressing 40.
I'm 48 now.
So this is I'm turning
40 now, at this time.
And I haven't changed nothing.
I haven't changed nothing.
I still have the same mentality.
I still have the same way of thinking.
And you know, I just
didn't change anything.
And at this time I'm 36 years old
and I'm still doing the same thing.
I don't know too many
people that have survived
that length of time.
But I you know, I don't
know if it was God.
I don't know what it was.
But I survived.
Now, I'm in Nevada and I am stuck.
I'm stranded.
I don't have nowhere to go.
But I have drugs.
So I walk around,
I find little places to
sit and shoot my dope.
I did that for my first night.
The second night, I woke up,
I was sitting on the curve
and it was raining and I was sick.
Because I had ran out of drugs.
Now I'm about maybe 22, 23
miles from Las Vegas Boulevard,
the city of Las Vegas.
Now I either go back that way
or I go the other way towards Los Angeles.
So I chose Los Angeles.
I started hitchhiking.
I meet a guy and his wife
on the highway back to Los Angeles.
And they're groupies, they like
to have sex with each other
and they like for guys
to watch them have sex,
and they're paid.
So I needed dope.
So I made the guy, basically what I did,
I kidnapped both of 'em.
And made them drive me to Los Angeles
before we do anything
so I can get my drugs.
So once I got to Los Angeles,
I ended up on Fifth and Crocker.
And I got me a gram of
dope and I did my dope.
And me and this couple rented
a room and we was in the room
for 11 days doing what we do.
You know, sexing each other,
partying, eating food,
throwing stuff around, not showering,
not doing anything that
normal humans does.
We didn't do any of that.
So as that passed, I
finally got to the point
where I robbed them.
They fell asleep one night
and they had traveler's checks
and a few currency.
So I took everything and I left.
I ended up on San Pedro and Sixth.
I went out and bought me a tent.
And I sat in my tent for
18 months shooting heron,
partying.
Doing the things that
criminals, street people does.
I did that.
So now, it's 2017.
This is another year.
I went out to buy some heron
and the police followed me
to the place to buy the drugs.
Because they knew me, from
me running around downtown,
all day, everyday.
So they had a good familiar of me.
And they followed me to
the dealer and they ran in
and as soon as the dealer
gave me the package
and I gave him the money,
they ran in and they arrested everybody.
They took me to jail.
I did another two years.
Well two and a half years on that case.
I got out 2019,
February.
I was out for four days
and I needed some heron,
because I had been missing it
for almost two and a half years.
I don't know why I needed
it, because I had did without
for two and a half years.
But I still in my mind and my craving,
being here on the streets
is a trigger for me.
So when I see the streets and
everything was still the same
I needed some heron.
And I went and got me some
heron, February of 2019.
And I got the heron.
I sat there, I did my
drugs on the streets.
It's a little place called Fresh Start.
I did it in front of there.
I did my dope and I passed out.
I basically OD'ed, okay.
Once I came to, I was in a
hospital with IVs all over me.
I just couldn't take it and
I snatched all that stuff off
and I walked out with a gown on.
I left all my property, everything,
because I needed some more heron.
So I ended up back on Fifth and Crocker
to get me some more heron.
And I got some more
heron and at that time,
I had heron still in the needle,
in my arm with me tied up
and passed out again.
At this time, it was the
police that stopped me
and came to me and took me to
jail for under the influence.
Okay, my record shows
that I'm a heron user,
I'm a dope dealer, I'm
a forger, I'm a burglar,
I'm all kind of things.
So the District Attorney
told me the only way
they're gonna put me in a program,
if I'll do a year in
the county jail first,
and then they will put me in a program.
I recently did the year in a county jail.
I was released March the 3rd, 2020.
And this is the end of my story.
- [Interviewer] All right Darnell.
Thank you very much.
Do you have kids of your own?
- Excuse me?
- [Interviewer] Do you have any children?
- No I don't, I don't.
- [Interviewer] No kids.
And you've been out how many days?
- Two days.
Well, what's today?
- [Interviewer] Today's Friday.
- I mean, what's the date?
I got out on the 3rd.
- [Interviewer] Today's March 6th.
- I've been out three days.
- [Interviewer] Three days.
- I got out on the 3rd.
I haven't done no dope or nothing.
- [Interviewer] So jail's a
great way to get clean, right?
- That's the only way I get clean.
- [Interviewer] So you're clean right now?
- Yes, been clean for three days.
We'll I've been clean
since the jail and now.
This is a trigger for me.
- [Interviewer] No shit?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So what do
you think the chances are
of you staying cleaning now?
- Well, I'm gonna use the resources.
I'm gonna work that first.
- [Interviewer] Get the fuck
out of this neighborhood.
- Exactly.
I'm gonna use the resources
and they're gonna send me...
(interviewer laughs)
they're gonna send me to a
program that's in Simi Valley.
So I've never been out there,
I don't know anything
about it, I'm going there.
I'm going there Monday.
Monday they're sending me.
- [Interviewer] It's like
you haven't had sex for three
years and you're in a brothel.
You just get the fuck out of here.
- I'm gonna go man.
- [Interviewer] You gotta get
out of here dude, right now.
- I got a lot more to go with that.
But I just wanted to give
you the basic things.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I know.
But I'm just worried about your next move.
- Yeah, hey.
It's been good, my three days.
I've slept in tents for the three days.
People coming and using drugs
and it didn't bother me.
So I know I'm on a good page.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
any family you can go to
or anything like that?
- Nothing here.
- [Interviewer] Nothing.
- Nothing here, nothing.
- [Interviewer] What about elsewhere?
- Excuse me?
Other cities?
- Oh yeah.
I have a auntie in Ohio and
I have someone in Texas.
And my sisters and brothers are in Texas.
- [Interviewer] Maybe rely on some family
for awhile just to...
- Well, they told me if I can clean up.
You know if I can stay clean,
while I'm on the streets,
not while I'm in jail.
This is the only thing that
my sisters and brothers don't like.
I get clean in jail.
- [Interviewer] No, I,
anybody can do that.
- You know, when I'm on
the streets, they tell me,
"You stay clean for six
months, I will send you a plane
"ticket, bring you here
and give you a job."
This is what my sister tells me.
- [Interviewer] No, and they're right too.
- And they're right man.
They are right man.
- [Interviewer] They're smart.
- You know.
I went out, I bought me some new shoes.
I ain't never done this.
I spent my money on heron, man.
I went out and bought shoes yesterday,
I bought pants, I bought
a shirt, I did this
and I didn't spend my money on heron.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- So I know I'm on a good page.
I know that not only Him,
but my heart is telling me,
"Try it, just try it.
"And see how far you can go with it."
- [Interviewer] I mean all
you gotta do is walk up
and down these streets and see what the...
(interviewer laughs)
it's hard.
- Man, when I ran into him, I was going.
He was like, "You got
somewhere to sleep tonight?"
I said, "No, so I'm just gonna kick it."
He said, "Look, come on
I got somebody I want you
"to talk to man.
"You wanna get your story off your chest?"
I said, "I've shared
my story before in AA."
He said, "No, you can get your story
"off your chest, for real."
So that's why he brung me here.
- [Interviewer] Cool.
Darnell I wish you luck and
I hope you get the hell out
of here as fast as possible.
- I do too man.
- [Interviewer] Because
you gotta be three times,
10 times as strong to resist here.
'cause it's every 10 feet.
- You know, last night, I slept in a tent
and every 20 minutes, someone
was coming over there.
And all I did was pull
a blanket over my head.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
you walk down any block,
there's what?
25 tents on that block.
Every single one of those tents,
is either heroine, crack, crystal meth.
- It's a real function disease man.
It's a function disease for the ones that,
I mean it's bad, man.
I've seen it, last night.
I mean every 20 minutes.
I'm just saying 20 minutes,
it might've been sooner than that.
But someone was coming in and he was like,
"Can they sit down?"
I was like, "Go ahead, I
just wanna go to sleep."
And they did they thing.
They did they thing.
And I could hear it.
I could hear the moans and how they...
I can hear everything and it's...
See, you know, a heron
junkie is a person that
he feels the power once he gets it.
He's weak as a puppy, without it.
But once he gets it, it's like Superman.
It's like the Krypton is gone.
You're no longer sitting
around the Krypton,
you're back with your strength.
And then when you put it in there,
you even get stronger
and not physically, not even mentally,
it's just something that you think.
That something that you
just run through your mind
and you're like, "Ahh."
You know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And I heard that last night man.
From different people,
sitting down doing it.
And that's something that I did for years.
And I always look for that.
It's something that you chase.
You wanna get that first feeling.
You know, and I was strong
enough to take that blanket
and cover over my head and
I really went to sleep.
And I woke up this morning,
I went and bought me
shoes and I felt good man.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Darnell] And I ain't
felt good like this
being on the streets, in a long time.
- [Interviewer] Well I
hope you stay strong.
- [Darnell] In a long time, man.
- [Interviewer] Stay strong, dude.
- [Darnell] All right.
I appreciate you taking my story in man.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, man.
- Love you for that man.
- [Interviewer] Good luck.
- Okay, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you, man.